now your first glimpse at dramatic new
images of the discovery of an American
warship lost seventy two years ago first
on CBS this morning this video shows the
moments a research vessel owned by
Microsoft co-founder Paul Allen found
the USS Indianapolis that ship soaked by
Japanese torpedoes in 1945 found way at
the bottom of the philippine sea
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is outside the world war 2
memorial in new york what details Vlad
goodmorning goodmorning the world war ii
memorial here at Battery Park is
dedicated to those service members who
lost their lives at sea the sinking of
the USS Indianapolis resulted in one of
the greatest losses of life from a
single ship in u.s. naval history of the
almost 1200 crew members on board only
one in four survived that's it we've got
it with the whole identification number
35 visible researchers found the USS
Indianapolis new video shows the ship's
distinct World War 2 era weapons this
photo shows those same weapons defending
the indy from japanese fighters Robert
Kraft led the expedition the depth of
water out here and the remote location
it makes it extremely difficult to mount
a search and be persistent enough be
successful new technology enabled the
crew of the RV portrayal to launch a
vehicle that could travel down more than
18,000 feet to the ocean floor she was
the most iconic and his Berkeley
significant ship at that time she just
completed a secret mission delivering
components for one of the two atomic
bombs to be dropped on Japan while
enroute to the Philippines to Japanese
torpedoes hit and sunk the ship Edgar
Harrell is one of the estimated 800 men
that escaped an SOS was never received
and no one knew they were missing we're
thirsty we're a hungry we are just
completely exhausted but we dare not
give up for four and a half days they
waited in shark-infested waters shark
would be coming through the group
and he would take someone fairly close
to you only 316 men were rescued Harrell
now 92 says he was afraid he would never
see the discovery of the USS
Indianapolis it still leaves open the
trauma of that experience but the fact
that we found the ship now and that
brings closure to the story of the end
Annapolis
the ships classified mission helped
bring the war to a close the exact
location of the ship still is classified
because it is a war grave and also
property of the US government of those
316 men that survived Nora only 19 are
still with us today
what an incredible story Vlad thank you
so much